-Today, Republicans exploded
into absolute chaos,
unlike here at this show,
on what was supposed to be
their first day in charge
of the House of Representatives
when a revolt by far-right
MAGA members
blocked GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy
from winning enough votes
to become
speaker
on the first two ballots.
It's the first time the House
has failed to elect a leader
on the first ballot in a century
and will almost certainly lead
to even more
GOP infighting and chaos.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
It would take far too long
to recount all
the political tumult
we experienced
in the year 2022 --
the January 6th revelations,
the sedition charges
for insurrectionists,
the criminal charges
for Trump cronies,
the FBI's search of Mar-a-Lago,
the Supreme Court decision
overturning Roe v. Wade,
the response
to Russia's war in Ukraine,
and the shocking
midterm election result
that defied decades
of historical precedent,
among many other things.
Now, if, after all of that,
you were hoping
that 2023 would usher
in a new era
of calm and normalcy,
then please allow me
to introduce you to one
Rudolph Giuliani, seen here,
realizing he wrote not just 2022
on a check today,
but also that he wrote "bribe"
in the memo.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Rudy was at Mar-a-Lago
to celebrate New Year's
with a bunch of other normal,
well-adjusted people,
and to ring in the New Year,
he recorded and then posted
online a very bizarre video
where you can't hear
a word he's saying.
We're going to show you the
video he himself posted online.
But again, none of this
will be intelligible to you
since he's completely drowned
out by the noise of the party,
but apparently
doesn't realize it.
[ Loud, indistinct music
playing ]
-[ Indistinct ]
♪♪
-Hats off to the band
for playing "Footloose"
for a crowd
that is almost certainly
medically incapable
of doing the "Footloose" dance.
"Footloose" sounds
like an excuse
Rudy would give
for being late to a meeting.
"Sorry, boss.
I got a foot loose.
The toes on the right one
are facing backwards,
so even when I run,
I go in a circle."
Also, this is just
some advice for anyone
on any screen,
myself included.
It's one of the first things
I learned in television.
Never lead with your chin.
No one's chin
is their finest attribute,
especially when
you're 78 years old.
If you fell asleep during Fallon
and woke up to me
looking like that,
you would change
the channel immediately.
Here, I'll prove it.
Hey.
[ Laughter ]
What happened?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You fall asleep?
You fall asleep during Fallon?
Well, we're happy to have you.
Check out the show.
There is one more thing
I have to point out
before we move on -- Rudy,
has since deleted this video,
but when he originally
posted it on Twitter,
he did so with the caption --
and this is 100% real...
Either Rudy
forgot what year it was
or he successfully
traveled exactly one year
into the future.
And honestly, I think
both explanations are feasible.
If Rudy had a DeLorean,
I absolutely believe
he would use it
to travel a comically
insignificant amount of time.
Rudy, where should we go?
Back to the Jurassic era?
Should we kill Hitler or should
we travel to the 30th century?
"I say we go one year
into the future.
I want to see
if my hair grows back.
I've been covering it
in chia seeds
and watering it for weeks."
[ Laughter ]
Now, Rudy may have been wrong
about what year it is,
but if today's stunning
political developments
are any indication,
I'm guessing his fellow
Republicans will give anything
to fast forward to 2024
because they're
currently embroiled
in a chaotic meltdown
over the future of their party.
On the very first day
they were supposed to be
in charge of the House
of Representatives,
GOP leader Kevin McCarthy
failed to win enough votes
on the first two ballots to
become Speaker of the House --
a monumental failure that
has not happened in 100 years.
-Longtime Trump ally
Kevin McCarthy
is facing a revolt from
far-right members of his caucus
who think the party's
only mistake
is not doing more
to embrace Trumpism.
-The results of this first round
of this high-stakes vote
for a new speaker
have now come in.
Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
had hoped to take the gavel
immediately
after the first ballot.
That will not happen.
The voting
will continue this afternoon.
He faces an uphill battle
within his own party --
a select few against him,
but enough of them to keep him
from getting the votes
he needed.
-Congressman Kevin McCarthy,
who can only afford
to lose four
House Republican votes
if he wants to become
the next speaker,
has lost five House Republican
votes,
six House Republican votes.
-McCarthy will not win
on the second ballot,
on the second vote
of the Republican Congress.
-That's right.
GOP leader Kevin McCarthy,
who has been fanatically
pro-Trump and spent years
ingratiating himself to Trump
in the MAGA movement,
is facing a backlash from
far-right members
of his own party who think
he's not pro-Trump enough.
And if there's
one political lesson
we've learned
in the past six years
is that there is always
someone more pro-Trump whenever.
Whatever line of decency
you draw in your head,
someone else is gonna walk right
through that mother[bleep].
I mean, even Trump himself
knows there are people out there
more pro-Trump than him.
I mean, people get
Donald Trump tattoos.
He wouldn't. He also couldn't.
His skinny so tough
you'd need a diamond-tip needle
just to leave a light smudge.
So now McCarthy has already lost
at least the first two votes,
imperiling his bid
to become speaker
and throwing
the GOP conference into chaos.
In fact, House Republicans
on either side of the fight
have been bickering,
calling each other names
and accusing each other
of backstabbing and betrayal.
-There's nothing
that indicates to me
that he's going to
change his pattern
since he's been
in leadership
where he's part
of the swamp cartel.
If you want to drain the swamp,
you cannot put
the biggest alligator
in charge of the exercise.
They're like.
Children. This is a this
is such a childish attempt
at gaining more
and more attention.
You know why they say
it like that?
Because they want you
to interview them again.
That's why they're doing it.
-I find out that it's my
Freedom Caucus colleagues
and my supposed friends
that went and did that.
And they asked nothing for me.
Nothing.
That's what I found out
in there. I'm furious.
-These people want to be taken
seriously as a governing party.
Meanwhile, they sound
like sorority members
who just got kicked out
for drinking too much.
"No one told me
there were any rules
against alcohol consumption.
And now I find out
from my supposed friends
that butt chugging is not
allowed?
Well, I am furious."
[ Laughter ]
Now, I'm not saying I'm enjoying
all this GOP infighting,
but when I heard
about McCarthy's troubles,
I did fly down to Mar-a-Lago
to party with Rudy Giuliani.
You should have seen us.
We spent all night
pounding shots of whiskey
mixed with prune juice
and dancing
to '80s movie soundtracks.
It was like if "White Lotus"
took place in a hospice.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh, who do you think
is going to die?
Everyone eventually.
Now, as we're taping this, we
still don't know
the final outcome, because the
House will have to keep voting
until someone
is elected speaker.
As of this afternoon, we don't
know when that will happen.
There's a chance you know
more about what happened
as you're watching this
than we do taping it.
It's almost like you traveled
eight hours into the future
with Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, the outcome
is so uncertain heading
in today's vote that many,
including Fox News,
were predicting it
could take days
or even weeks
for the Republicans
to finally elect a speaker.
-McCarthy needs the votes of all
but four House Republicans
to win the speakership,
but at least 5 and as many as
14 House Republicans oppose him.
It could be the first time
in a century
the speaker's vote isn't settled
on the first ballot.
-Back in the Civil War times,
there was one speaker who was
not elected for two months
and it took 133 votes.
-Alright, first of all,
it's not a great sign
for your party's
political fortunes
when pundits are comparing
your situation
to something that happened,
"back in the Civil War times."
[ Laughter ]
Also, diggin' 2023 Steve Doocy
talking like an old prospector
huddled around a campfire
with a tin of beans.
"Back in the Civil War times,
there weren't no fancy phones
or gizmo.
All we had was our wits.
Well, not all of us had them."
[ Laughter ]
So much for my resolution --
to make less fun
of Rudy Giuliani this year.
They all deserve this,
especially McCarthy,
who is so desperate for power
he infamously flew down
to Mar-a-Lago
for that embarrassing photo op
with Donald Trump
just weeks after
the January 6th insurrection.
Remember that?
McCarthy did everything
he could to cozy up to Trump
and the MAGA circus
in the House,
and he's still facing a revolt
from the looniest members
of the GOP.
-He is, of course, gotten very
close to Donald Trump.
He rehabilitated Donald Trump.
I think all of these things
were in an effort
to be able to, when the moment
came, to tell these people,
"You can trust me,
I'm a conservative.
I'm on your side.
I'm with the team."
-I think all of those things
were explained by him
wanting to be able to get the
gavel on the first ballot today.
And if he doesn't,
and it's looking increasingly
like he won't,
this will be the first time
we've seen this
in our lifetimes.
This is only happened
once since the Civil War,
and I think it will badly,
badly weaken him.
-Did McCarthy think one visit
to Mar-a-Lago
was going to magically
solve everything?
That place is the opposite
of Disney World.
It's where dreams go to die.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, so, no, wait. So it's
the same as Disney World.
If you ever find yourself
at Mar-a-Lago
and you're not wearing
a blue windbreaker
with FBI on the back,
that's how you know you took
some wrong turns in life.
It's like waking up
at a hotel in Tijuana
with a bag of white powder
on your nightstand,
a stranger in your bathtub,
and loud knocking on the door
while someone yells,
"Policía. Abre la puerta."
You're not, when you hear that,
going to look in the mirror
and think to yourself,
"This current year,
2024, is off to a great start."
But maybe the craziest aspect
of this debacle
was all the speculation
beforehand about who,
if anyone, could beat McCarthy
if he lost the speaker vote.
Several names
were floated before today.
And on Fox News,
one of the far-right Republicans
revolting against McCarthy
refused to rule out
one of the most
farfetched hypotheticals
involving you know who.
-I've heard from people at
the House Freedom Caucus
that they like two names
out there --
Steve Scalise and Donald Trump.
-Well, I'm sure we do like it,
but I don't think
they're the right people
for speaker.
They may be, but we should
have a conversation.
-That's right. Some of them
were actively floating Trump
as a possible speaker of the
House before the votes today,
because technically you don't
have to be a member of Congress.
In fact, you don't even have
to be human, as far as I know.
Republicans
could end up picking
a meth-addicted Florida
crocodile with a beer can helmet
and a golf cart
with a bumper sticker that says,
"My other ride is your mom."
[ Laughter ]
The main reason we did that joke
is to see
what Graphics came up with.
There's always a fear
after a long hiatus
that their skills will atrophy.
But as you can see,
we good.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway --
Yeah, give it up for Graphics.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anyway,
can you imagine Donald Trump
as speaker of the House?
He doesn't even qualify for any
of the words in the job title.
He lives in a beach resort,
not a house,
and he's not very good
at speaking.
-10,000 known or "suspested"
gang members...
...controlled by
large "derners"...
Every single car out there, even
the really "expensis" ones...
God bless the United "Shates."
They sacrifice every day
for the "furniture" -- future
of their children.
Unelected "regu-lators"
and regulators...
The "corradors" of power or --
They're our "corradors."
They're not their "corradors"
These are our "corradors."
-As insane as it would be,
I would love to hear Trump's
first address as
Speaker of the House.
"Welcome, everyone,
to the [indistinct].
We love our 'corradors,'
don't we, folks?
We love corradors
because we're the 'core'
and we control the 'doors'
and that's the core, you know?
If you follow -- if you follow
me down this corridor,
it'll lead to another
corridor which will in turn
lead to a third --
a third corridor...
where you can get the [bleep]
out
because I'm not gonna listen to
a God damn thing
you have to say.
'Corrador.'"
This was supposed
to be Republicans' first day
in charge of the House,
a day on which they were hoping
to be taken seriously
as a governing party,
and instead they imploded
into absolute chaos.
Whoever ends up as their leader,
today's meltdown should be yet
another reminder
that the current
Republican Party
simply isn't fit to govern.
And when it comes to Congress,
they shouldn't even be allowed
in the doors,
much less the...
-"Corradors."
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]